RICK SCOTT TESTING POSITIVE FOR
COVID-19.
>> Martha: FOX NEWS ALERT.
MARYLAND’S GOVERNOR LARRY HOGAN
TIGHTENING HIS STATE’S COVID-19
RESTRICTIONS THEY INCLUDE A
10:00 P.M. CURFEW FOR BARS AND
RESTAURANTS.
CAPACITY LIMITS AS STORES,
SALONS, HOUSES OF WORSHIP WILL
BE LOWERED.
HOSPITAL AND NURSING HOME
VISITS SUSPENDED.
NO FANS ALLOWED AT SPORTING
EVENTS.
MARYLAND HAS MORE THAN 1,000
CASES A DAY FOR TWO WEEKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH US THIS
MORNING.
IT’S GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH US.
I THINK THESE ARE THINGS THAT
EVERYBODY HAS WANTED TO AVOID,
I WOULD IMAGINE THAT YOU HAD
HOPED TO AVOID THEM AS WELL.
WHY DO YOU THINK THIS IS THE
BEST COURSE OF ACTION AT THIS
POINT?
>> WELL WE’VE BEEN DOING REALLY
WELL ON ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND
ON THE VIRUS.
WE WERE BETTER THAN 43 OTHER
STATES.
WE’VE HAD OUR ECONOMY 100% OPEN
SINCE JULY OR AUGUST.
BUT NOW WE’RE SEEING THE VIRUS
UNFORTUNATELY DOESN’T RECOGNIZE
STATE BORDERS AND IT IS SPIKING
OUT OF CONTROL ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IN ALL 50 STATES.
WE’VE HIT OUR LARGEST PEAK EVER.
WE’VE BEEN OVER 2,000, 2300
CASES A COUPLE DAYS IN A ROW.
THE BIGGEST CONCERN WE HAVE IS
THE HOSPITALIZATIONS, HAPPENING
IN MANY STATES.
WE’RE AT 90% CAPACITY.
A NUMBER OF HOSPITALS THAT ARE
OVER CAPACITY AND WE HAD 25
DEATHS IN THE PAST 24 HOURS.
WE HAVE A PERSON DYING EVERY
MINUTE IN AMERICA BUT ONE EVERY
HOUR HERE IN THE STATE OF
MARYLAND.
>> Martha: A COUPLE OF
CONFLICTING INPUTS ON YOUR
ACTION.
ONE COMING FROM THE MONTGOMERY
COUNTY EXECUTIVE SAYING THE
GOVERNOR HAD STRONG WORDS BUT I
DON’T THINK THE STEPS THAT HE
TOOK MATCH THE URGENCY OF HIS
WORDS.
WE MUST TAKE SIGNIFICANT
MEASURES TO SLOW THE SPREAD.
AND THEN THE DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
INDEPENDENT BUSINESSES HAS A
DIFFERENT TAKE.
HE SAYS IT’S A VERY SAD DAY FOR
MARYLAND BUSINESSES.
IT WILL BE A TOUGH PILL TO
SWALLOW FOR SO MANY OF THE
STATE’S JOB CREATORS.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO BOTH OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS ABOUT YOUR
DECISION?
>> WELL LOOK, YOU WILL NEVER
MAKE EVERYBODY HAPPEN.
THESE ARE TERRIBLE DECISIONS.
A CHOICE BETWEEN A BAD CHOICE
AND A BAD CHOICE.
I AM A LIFETIME SMALL
BUSINESSMAN.
I RAN FOR GOVERNOR TO HELP
SMALL BUSINESSES.
WE TRY TO KEEP OUR HOSPITALS
FROM OVERFLOWING AND LOSING
THEIR BUSINESSES OR LIVES.
WE ARE TRYING TO FIND THE
BALANCE.
89% OF THE PEOPLE IN MARYLAND
BELIEVE THAT WE’VE GOT IT JUST
ABOUT RIGHT.
THERE ARE A FEW ON ONE SIDE
THINK WE’RE NOT DOING ENOUGH.
A FEW ON THE OTHER SIDE THAT
THINK WE’RE DOING TOO MUCH.
I DON’T CARE WHAT PEOPLE THINK.
WE’RE MAKING THE DECISIONS
BASED ON THE BEST ADVICE AND
WE’RE HOPING TO GET IT RIGHT.
>> Martha: I KNOW YOU WERE ON
THE CALL YESTERDAY WITH
PRESIDENT-ELECT JOE BIDEN ABOUT
CORONAVIRUS.
WHAT WAS YOUR TAKEAWAY FROM
THAT?
AND HOW DO YOU SEE HIM HANDLING
THIS ANY DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
WE’VE HAD IN THE PAST?
>> RIGHT.
SO WE HAD A REALLY PRODUCTIVE
MEETING WITH VICE PRESIDENT
PENCE AND THE WHITE HOUSE
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE ON
TUESDAY.
WE HAD WHAT I THOUGHT WAS A
PRODUCTIVE MEETING YESTERDAY
WITH VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
SENATOR HARRIS.
THIS WAS THE EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE ON THE NATIONAL
GOVERNOR’S ASSOCIATION.
FIVE REPUBLICANS AND FIVE
DEMOCRATS.
THEY WERE MOSTLY IN LISTENING
MODE.
THEY DIDN’T TALK A LOT ABOUT
THEIR PLANS BUT WE THOUGHT IT
WAS IMPORTANT THE GOVERNORS ON
THE FRONT LINE OF FIGHTING THIS
BATTLE SINCE FOR NINE MONTHS
NOW AND IT GAVE US A CHANCE TO
TELL THEM WHAT WE SAW GOING ON
AND WHAT WERE THE THINGS WE
NEEDED TO CONTINUE AND SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT WE THOUGHT WE
NEEDED HELP ON LIKE WE WANT TO
GET THE NEXT STIMULUS PACKAGE.
SOME KIND OF COMPROMISE BETWEEN
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS.
GREAT PROGRESS ON THE VACCINE
WITH OPERATION WARP SPEED IS
ONE OF THE BIGGEST SUCCESSES OF
THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE NOBODY IS
DROPPING THE BALLS AS WE’RE
GOING THROUGH THIS TRANSITION.
>> Martha: GOVERNOR HOGAN,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.